Words matter.
They can heal
and they can kill ...
yet, they have a limit.
When I was in eighth grade,
my teacher gave me a vocabulary sheet
with the word "genocide."
I hated it.
The word genocide is clinical ...
overgeneral ...
bloodless ...
dehumanizing.
No word
can describe
what this does to a nation.
You need to know,
in this kind of war,
husbands kills wives,
wives kill husbands,
neighbors and friends kill each other.
Someone
in power
says,
"Those over there ...
they don't belong.
They're not human."
And people believe it.
I don't want words
to describe this kind of behavior.
I want words to stop it.
But where are the words to stop this?
And how do we find the words?
But I believe, truly,
we have to keep trying.
I was born in Kigali, Rwanda.
I felt loved by my entire family
and my neighbors.
I was constantly
being teased by everybody,
especially my two older siblings.
When I lost my front tooth,
my brother looked at me and said,
"Oh, it has happened to you, too?
It will never grow back."
(Laughter)
I enjoyed playing everywhere,
especially my mother's garden
and my neighbor's.
I loved my kindergarten.
We sang songs,
we played everywhere
and ate lunch.
I had a childhood
that I would wish for anyone.
But when I was six,
the adults in my family
began to speak in whispers
and shushed me any time
that I asked a question.
One night,
my mom and dad came.
They had this strange look
when they woke us.
They sent my older sister Claire and I
to our grandparent's,
hoping whatever was happening
would blow away.
Soon we had to escape from there, too.
We hid,
we crawled,
we sometimes ran.
Sometimes I heard laughter
and then screaming and crying
and then noise that I had never heard.
You see,
I did not know
what those noises were.
They were neither human --
and also at the same time,
they were human.
I saw people who were not breathing.
I thought they were asleep.
I still didn't understand what death was,
or killing in itself.
When we would stop
to rest for a little bit
or search for food,
I would close my eyes,
hoping when I opened them,
I would be awake.
I had no idea which direction was home.
Days were for hiding
and night for walking.
You go from a person who's away from home
to a person with no home.
The place that is supposed to want you
has pushed you out,
and no one takes you in.
You are unwanted
by anyone.
You are a refugee.
From age six to 12,
I lived in seven different countries,
moving from one refugee camp to another,
hoping we would be wanted.
My older sister Claire,
she became a young mother ...
and a master at getting things done.
When I was 12,
I came to America with Claire
and her family on refugee status.
And that's only the beginning,
because even though I was 12 years old,
sometimes I felt like three years old
and sometimes 50 years old.
My past receded,
grew jumbled,
distorted.
Everything was too much
and nothing.
Time seemed like pages torn out of a book
and scattered everywhere.
This still happens to me
standing right here.
After I got to America,
Claire and I did not talk about our past.
In 2006,
after 12 years
being separated away from my family,
and then seven years
knowing that they were dead
and them thinking that we were dead,
we reunited ...
in the most dramatic,
American way possible.
Live,
on television --
(Laughter)
on "The Oprah Show."
(Applause)
I told you, I told you.
(Laughter)
But after the show,
as I spent time with my mom and dad
and my little sister
and my two new siblings that I never met,
I felt anger.
I felt every deep pain in me.
And I know that
there is absolutely nothing,
nothing,
that could restore the time
we lost with each other
and the relationship we could've had.
Soon, my parents
moved to the United States,
but like Claire,
they don't talk about our past.
They live in never-ending present.
Not asking too many questions,
not allowing themselves to feel --
moving in small steps.
None of us, of course,
can make sense of what happened to us.
Though my family is alive --
yes, we were broken,
and yes, we are numb
and we were silenced
by our own experience.
It's not just my family.
Rwanda is not the only country
where people have turned on each other
and murdered each other.
The entire human race,
in many ways,
is like my family.
Not dead;
yes, broken, numb and silenced
by the violence of the world
that has taken over.
You see,
the chaos of the violence continues inside
in the words we use
and the stories
we create every single day.
But also on the labels
that we impose on ourselves
and each other.
Once we call someone "other,"
"less than,"
"one of them"
or "better than,"
believe me ...
under the right condition,
it's a short path to more destruction.
More chaos
and more noise
that we will not understand.
Words will never be enough
to quantify and qualify
the many magnitudes
of human-caused destruction.
In order for us
to stop the violence
that goes on in the world,
I hope --
at least I beg you --
to pause.
Let's ask ourselves:
Who are we without words?
Who are we without labels?
Who are we in our breath?
Who are we in our heartbeat?
(Applause)